[Music]
[Music]
you know what a courtesy tap is young
man it sounds like this it's light
friendly I'm sure that's what your mom
meant to kill no it's not mom
having a kind of a hard time like I'm
sorry
accept my apology see where I am if you
could just do the same we could press
reset don't have anything to apologize
for
[Music]
can you go
ma'am are you okay I'm pretty sure the
guy in that trucks following me
these road-raging wanted this chilled
man go your way
I don't think you really know what a bad
day is
you go find out
that man stole my phone Eddie I'm
sitting here and waiting for you whose
phone is on I cross me friend hey listen
to me
he's not a friend okay he's the psycho
who came after me today
this is where your first lesson begins
no I can't do that
I need you to learn what a bad day
really is I need you to learn how to say
sorry yeah you're gonna learn to fine on
some retribution wait you better bring
your A game
you're gonna need it
[Music]